[Music]
hi
i'm isaac in this video i'm going to
give you an overview of apogee's api
monetization capabilities
many businesses have digital assets apis
are the interface that enable developers
to leverage those digital assets
such apis can be considered products
with developers as the customers
there are many ways businesses can
derive value from apis
exposing apis can result in
co-innovation with developers
and opens up the potential to grow new
ecosystems around your digital assets
and services
in some cases your api products present
the opportunity to create
whole new direct revenue models api
monetization is a key way to unlock
value from your digital assets
and even increase api adoption by
building custom packages
tailored to developer needs it enables
api providers
to reach beyond current business models
and open new opportunities with
customers developers and partners
the apigee api management platform
provides a powerful and flexible api
monetization solution
that is being used by global enterprises
today
it enables you to package valuable
digital assets into monetizable products
that can be easily consumed by
developers you can create rules to
define which api calls qualifiers
monetize transactions
and to enforce monetization limits on
api usage
if you take credit card payments from
developers apogee makes things like pci
dss compliance certificates
straightforward and simple apogee also
gives you the ability to build
innovative business models through api
monetization
you can choose from revenue sharing
usage-based billing subscriptions
freemium
and many other pre-built models you can
easily create rate plans and manage
renewals
apigee api monetization also supports
multiple currencies
and provides for easy integration into
your billing systems
having a monetization strategy doesn't
necessarily guarantee success
a developer portal is often important so
that consumers of your apis can quickly
and securely gain access to the tools
and information they need
to explore test and consume them a
monetization engine
should be integrated seamlessly with the
portal to simplify how you publish api
packages
process payments and meter transactions
when your apis drive direct revenue it
becomes even more important for you to
monitor and analyze usage
with apogee you get out of the box
monitoring capabilities
that enable you to deliver consistently
high service levels
apogee api monetization also includes
detailed reporting
on api traffic based on developer
consumption including any refunds
adjustments and service credits
it offers robust billing capabilities
including taxes and international
support
okay that's a quick introduction to
apogee api monetization
if you're already an apigee customer
contact your sales representative to get
started
if you're not already an apogee customer
try it for free
that's it from me till next time